okay what really really but like I've
never played spin the bottle before
growing up I used to see it in American
movies and just really want to play it
because all the cool kids would play it
and I was kind of a bit dorky as a kid
so now's my chance even if I was invited
to play spin-the-bottle I wouldn't have
been able to do it I was afraid of
tongues
mouths girls perfumes it all just gave
me anxiety I feel like I was robbed a
little bit of my childhood because I
didn't play spin-the-bottle I'm so
nervous to play spin-the-bottle right
now
I'll probably bump heads with someone
and that's just gonna be a little bit
awkward I'm more introverted so it's
difficult for me to talk to a stranger
let alone you know kiss someone I wasn't
cool enough for that do this alright
where are we going right no the first
you should have shaved this and this
side of the room has gotten a lot of
action there's so good yeah you're the
one okay the next Bachelorette okay what
really really but like
I'm really giggling
yeah
I think it was just nice that we were
like a chill group of people we didn't
really know each other but like he still
were able to be vulnerable and chill
about it everyone was just like in it
for fun and games
it wasn't like high pressure situation
like I thought of it as a kid I think
kids want to play spin the bottle
because it makes them feel like adults
but as an adult playing spin the bottle
it just made me feel like a kid again